well III have a lot of that when I do
professionally but if you want one
fragment of it I would say that the more
that you move towards that part of the
advancing frontier of scientific
knowledge and its application and that
part of it that deals with the
environment the better career you will
have and in terms of opportunities
opening now in this century and in the
obvious impact that you're going to have
there are other areas obviously like
medicine but environment is it's the one
that's opening up big time right now in
every way opportunities new discoveries
to be made practical applications that
have tremendous positive impact